sugar beet farmer Matthias krieg is
pleased despite the dry spring the
harvest is good the sugar beets are
well-formed and heavy there's a long
tradition of cultivating beats in this
region but drastic sugar market reforms
may change that the class is all good
the main concern of farmers in our
region is that they'll no longer be able
to produce sugar beets for the offering
price the base price because it's too
low quality on Conan it might not even
cover the costs of production body
pollutants custom architecture Adam a
half an hour away insights there's a
factory that belongs to the world's
leading sugar producer Zuka it's one of
eight plants in Germany at full
production the factory processes 600
truckloads of sugar beets a day but the
beets go through a complicated process
due to EU regulations capping production
quantity and tumbling sugar prices it's
difficult for zood saga to make a profit
plant manager Philip shuda is worried
about the future he hasn't under
pressure at the moment we're not earning
enough to cover costs and we will incur
losses in our sugar beet division this
year chef Geum as soon as sugar quotas
are lifted the company will be able to
produce and sell as much as it wants so
it's planning to expand internationally
as well executives are considering
Brazil the world's largest sugar market
it's difficult to predict how that will
affect farmers growing sugar beets used
to be very lucrative for them but after
2017 they may see tougher times